vielleicht die erste Frage an Sie
Wasserknappheit in Uruguay Wasser
Notstand im Süden Spaniens Waldbrände in
Mecklenburg in Brandenburg Feuer in
Kanada die New York im gelben Rauch
versinken lassen was sehen wir da ist
das Wetter oder ist das Klima
wir sehen zunächst dass das Wetter ist
weil zu Waldbränden und um die geht ja
gerade und wir sehen hier gerade die
Bilder aus Kanada
gehören mehrere Zutaten und das ist
einmal Hitze es braucht Trockenheit und
dann Bauch ist Wälder und sozusagen den
Grundstoff den Zunder wenn man so will
damit so einen Wald Brand ausbrechen
kann und dann gehört Wind dazu also es
ist eine Kombination aus diesen Faktoren
und am Ende steht der Mensch weil die
meisten Waldbrände auch heute werden
durch tatsächlich menschliche Tun
ausgelöst und nicht so wie es eigentlich
ähm in vielen anderen Gebieten ist durch
natürliche Faktoren wie Blitzschlag z.B
sondern dadurch dass der Mensch tätig
ist und viele brennende brechen in der
Nähe von Siedlungen aus ist der Mensch
dann oft auch als Auslöser beteiligt
diese Bilder hier nicht das ist beklem
ne wenn man das sieht das ist New York
das sind die und das ist ja das was kann
Tage her ne ja ist ein paar Tage her das
macht ja die Branding Kanada raus die
sind nicht ungewöhnlich an sich sind von
der Größe von der flächenhaftigkeit von
der flächenhaften Ausdehnung her
ungewöhnlich und sie sind eben so groß
man sieht sie ja auch auf den
Satellitenbildern aus dem All das ist
wirklich eine eine eine riesen Dimension
hat ja neue Dimensionen ist das ja in
der Flächenausdehnung nicht so sehr in
der Häufigkeit aber in der Flächen
Ausdehnung und auch zum der Zeitpunkt
das ist jetzt so zu früh im Jahr ist ist
es in mehreren Aspekten ungewöhnlich das
finde ich nämlich so interessant sie
sind muss man vorweg finde ich einmal
klar machen Sie sie gehören nicht in die
Alarmismus Abteilung nein gar nicht und
deswegen freue ich mich dass Sie unsere
Einladung gefolgt sind weil sie sehr
differenziert auf all das schauen was da
passiert aber sie sagen es gibt so ein
paar Punkte ein paar Dinge über die
müssen wir nachdenken und darüber müssen
wir wirklich ernsthaft sprechen zum
Beispiel auch das die Frage dass das
jetzt passiert was ist daran so
natürlich
jetzt bezogen auf die Waldbrände ist es
eben die die die Vielzahl es ist die
Flächen Ausdehnung es ist die die
Jahreszeit zu der das passiert die in
der Summe eben mehrere ungewöhnliche
Ausprägung hat aber das gilt auch für
die Waldbrände die wir jetzt gerade hier
in Deutschland wieder sehen denn man
könnte sich auch das Szenario vorstellen
dass es flächenhafte und große
Waldbrände vor den Toren Hamburgs in der
Lüneburger Heide gibt die hat ja auch
1976 schon mal gegeben wir haben die
Brände wir sehen die Waldbrand
Gefahrenkarte gerade im Hintergrund
auf der Karte dessen du größer diese
Waldbrand gefahren und auch große Brände
und die Wälder würden bisher geben in
Brandenburg solche Bilder werden auch
für Berlin vorstellbar
rund um Berlin oder die Stadt selber die
Stadt also wenn ein großer flächenhafter
Waldbrand in diesem Dimensionen östlich
von Berlin ausbrechen würde und wir
haben gerade Ostwind dann sind solche
Bilder wie sie jetzt für New York
gesehen haben auch für Berlin denke
das klingt nicht gut was so seltsam ist
ist das Gefühl in diesem Jahr Frank auch
in die Runde das Gefühl war doch ein
anderes das Gefühl war und ich weiß noch
ich habe mit jemandem auch Kindersendung
darüber gesprochen der sagt ja in diesem
Jahr ist Wasser ist Trockenheit nicht
unser Thema
der Winter war vergleichsweise nass es
hat gut geregnet die Grundwasserspeicher
in Deutschland sind relativ gut gefüllt
und plötzlich wie aus dem Nichts von
einem Moment auf den anderen sitzen wir
hier und reden genau darüber dass es
plötzlich wieder so unfassbar trocken
wird was ist denn da wirklich passiert
wir müssen in die Dimension des
Wasserkreislaufs denken und diese Dürre
die wir jetzt mit der wir es jetzt zu
tun haben ist ja eine die schon seit
mindestens 2017
da ist und ein zusammenhängendes
Ereignis ist reden eigentlich über eine
Periode eine Dürre Periode und nicht
über Dürrejahre und die
niederschlagsdefizite die sich im
Wasserkreislauf aufgebaut haben
die eben begonnen haben in diesen Jahren
die nicht wieder in den Wind dann
ausgefüllt sind sind mittlerweile so
hoch man kann das für einzelne ähm
Teile Deutschlands finanzieren uns
fehlen in einzelnen Regelungen
anderthalb Jahre Niederschlag mit
anderen Worten es müsste anderthalb
Jahre kontinuierlich rechnen damit diese
Defizite wieder ausgeführt werden
anderthalb Jahre Regen in der Zeit in
der Grundwasser Neubildung ja und das
ist das lange Gedächtnis dass der
Wasserkreislauf hat wir haben es mit
einem Problem zu tun dass weit über den
Tag und weit über ein Jahr hinausreicht
und eben
wie gesagt als dem Wasserkreislauf
heraus verstanden werden muss denn
Grundwasser dass wir heute vielleicht
aus unserem Wasserhahn bekommen und von
den Wasserwerken gewonnen wird aus
vielleicht 100 Meter Tiefe hat
vielleicht 100 Jahre gebraucht um
dorthin zu kommen wir reden über solche
Zeitskalen so langsam geht das das kann
doch durchaus länger gehen
während das Wasser dass wir jetzt und
wir sehen gerade den dürrenmonitor im
Hintergrund das ist der Oberboden in
Deutschland die obersten zwei Meter okay
zwei Meter so ist das definiert so ist
das definiert da reden wir über die
Bodenfeuchte nicht über das Grundwasser
sondern das Wasser das in den oberen
Bodenschichten gebunden ist dort den
Pflanzen vor allen Dingen zur Verfügung
steht das wird eher durch jährliche
Niederlage Schläge
aufgefüllt in die tieferen
Bodenschichten dauerte schon mehrere
Jahre also bei zwei Metern und deswegen
kommt die kuriose Situation zustande das
ist zwar dann wie jetzt im Januar regnet
oder im Februar der Oberboden ist feucht
die oben 30 cm und da drunter ist es
trocken wie in der Steppe und das macht
eben der Wasserkreislauf
okay zwei Fragen dazu also es klingt so
als würden Sie sagen das ist ein Thema
ein Problem um das geht auch nicht mehr
weg
das ist ein Thema wir müssen lernen mit
diesen neuen extremen und das macht
jetzt auch diese Dürre diese Dürre
Periode den letzten fünf Jahre aus wenn
man die mal versucht statistisch
einzuordnen da gibt es Analysen die
sagen dass das in den letzten 2000
Jahren im Mitteleuropa so nicht
vorgekommen ist seit anderthalb Jahre
mit anderen Worten wir haben es mit
einer neuen
Situation zu tun auf die wir uns
einstellen müssen und dass wir fünf
trockenen Jahre in Folge haben ist eine
neue Qualität das hat früher schon mal
einzelne trockenjahre gegeben aber die
sind dann tatsächlich durch ein feuchtes
Folgejahr sehr schnell wieder abgelöst
worden und dann auch von Perioden in
denen es dann mehr geregnet hat aber das
ist die neue Qualität dieses Ereignis
ist mit denen wir jetzt zu tun haben
neulich eine Statistik gelesen ich habe
sie nicht mehr ganz präzise im Kopf aber
EU Gebiet wie viel das gesamten
eu-gebiets sind mittlerweile von von
wirklich von von Dürre bedroht also auf
dem Weg dahin Dürre Gebete zu werden
wir haben Dürre Gebiete ja schon immer
der der mittelbärraum wir haben von
Spanien gehört Südfrankreich die auch
natürlich schon immer
niederschlagsärmere Gebiete waren genau
der Punkt ist aber dass sich die und das
sagen die Prognosen die man wirklich
ernst nehmen muss dass wir wenn wir uns
so in Richtung
20150/2016 bewegen also die Jahrzehnte
in den der Klimawandel richtig manifest
wird dass wir dann vielleicht 20 30 40%
der Fläche Mittel Europas in so einem
Zustand haben wie wir gerade auf dem
Foto sehen
20 30 40 %.
spannend ist gerade als Stichwort
gefallen Herr etter sie leben da das ist
die Hauptwohnsitz sozusagen spannend ist
gerade sehr betroffen von Dürren es gibt
unglaubliche Bilder die wir gerade aus
Spanien sehen ähm der der Sommer beginnt
ja gerade erst richtig genau wo ich lebe
ist es noch relativ feucht
vergleichsweise wo ist das das ist im
Norden an der Grenze zu Frankreich im
Vorgebirge der Pyrenäen genau und es war
jetzt auch wieder die kuriose Situation
dass es da bei uns in der Nähe
tatsächlich was wir gerade sehen ähm das
ist jetzt die letzten Wochen sehr sehr
viel geregnet hat aber wir haben so
einen kleinen Fluss der durch das Tal
führt der hat sich nicht erholt seit
vergangenen Sommer das war wirklich so
ein massiver Einschnitt den man da
wirklich beobachten konnte
das und das gleichzeitig wir sind halt
nicht davorbereitet wir haben also es
ist glaube ich überall so ein in Europa
bei uns ist keine wasserfabrik die soll
jetzt erweitert werden das macht
natürlich überhaupt keinen Sinn aber es
wird halt weiter vorangetrieben und
bei uns ist es noch relativ harmlos wenn
er weiterhin im Süden Spaniens gehen da
haben wir die Olivenernte und olivenen
sind ja eigentlich Bäume die vertragen
Hitze die vertragen Dürre die ist in
Andalusien teilweise um 80% eingebrochen
und das ist irgendwie ein Warnzeichen
dass ich da beobachtet habe was mir sehr
sehr große Sorgen gemacht hat
wenn wir gerade über ernten sprechen ich
habe das vorhin zitiert teilweise ernten
die um ein Drittel kleiner geringer
ausfallen als noch vor wenigen Jahren
Magdeburger Börde sehr sehr fruchtbarer
Boden gutes guter Boden aber immer
weniger Wasser
das etwas bedeutet das für Deutschland
an welchem Punkt wird es irgendwann
existenziell ich meine wenn man mal
anfängt darüber nachzudenken wir gehen
morgens zum Bäcker kaufen wir
selbstverständlich unser Brötchen wann
haben wir irgendwann die Situation dass
wir Weizen selber nicht mehr haben und
auch woanders nicht mehr kriegen
möglicherweise also an welchem Punkt
müssen wir anfangen darüber nachzudenken
was wir schlicht und ergreifend an
Nahrungsmittel noch herstellen können
also erstmal ist richtig und
festzuhalten dass die nahrungs- und
Mittel also dass der
Ernährungssicherheit auf Ängste mit
Wasser verknüpft ist ja denn ähm
aufgrund genau dieser Zusammenhänge es
heißt für und die Landwirtschaft in
Deutschland und auch im Mitteleuropa
nichts anderes als jetzt das Anpassung
erfolgen muss nämlich mit diesen
veränderten Bedingungen umzugehen und
ich mache das mal an der Zahl fest in
Deutschland werden im Moment nur und
zwei Prozent der landwirtschaftlichen
Fläche bewässert das ist ja ein anderen
Gegenden wie Spanien ganz anders wie wir
wissen das heißt es gibt jetzt eine
massive Diskussion darüber in die
landwirtschaftliche Bewässerung zu gehen
und die landwirtschaftliche Bewässerung
bedeutet da kommt ein völlig neuer
wassernutzer vielleicht müssen wir in 30
Jahren 30 40 Prozent der
landwirtschaftlichen Nutzfläche nämlich
auf den fruchtbaren Böden bewässern aber
das Wasser muss irgendwo herkommen das
kann eigentlich nur aus dem Grundwasser
oder aus Oberflächenwasser kommen also
da wo es heute noch erstmal auf diese
Art und Weise genutzt wird und wenn wir
beim Grundwasser sind sind wir bei der
Nutzungskonkurrenz zum Trinkwasser denn
die große Frage wird sein ist denn für
beide Nutzung landwirtschaftliche
Bewässerung und Trinkwasser dann genug
da und um diese Frage geht es und darum
geht's
Trinkwasser versus Bewässerung für
Landwirtschaft das ist eine der
zukünftigen man könnte sagen es geht um
Essen oder Trinken es geht um
Nutzungskonkurrenz und wir müssen
aushandeln und wir müssen uns jetzt
überlegen mit den Prognosen die wir für
die Wasserbilanz haben also wie viel
Wasser ist da wer nutzt welche Menge und
wer bekommt es im knappheitsfall
vielleicht zuerst und wir müssen uns
überlegen wie aus einer
Nutzungskonkurrenz am besten kein
Konflikt wird sondern man muss sich
vorher überlegen wie man in diesen
krisenhaften Situationen umgeht und dann
muss man sich und das gilt ja auch für
die landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe und
die Landwirtschaft langfristig überlegen
muss man andere Früchte umbauen braucht
man andere Beispiel können sie mal
konkret machen was was könnte das in der
Projektion bedeuten das kann sein dass
man zum Beispiel wasserintensive
Kulturen wie Mais den wir vielleicht gar
nicht sinnvoll nutzen können übrigens
auch nicht für für die Ernährung das
dann vielleicht dass keine keine
Nutzpflanze ist die wir hier noch
anbauen sollten während das für Weizen
sicherlich anders zu sehen ist also das
sind die Fragen die dann zu stellen sind
und für die Betriebe bedeutet es
natürlich wie schaffen Sie es dann auf
Weltmärkten zu bestehen und als Betriebe
zu überlegen das heißt sie brauchen
betriebliche
Existenzbedingungen das ist die
Herausforderung der Zukunft und die ist
anders als die die wir im Moment noch
gegeben haben immer was da jetzt im Raum
steht ist ja das rationieren von Wasser
ne darüber denken wir dann
offensichtlich nach es kann ja es geht
auch bis in die Rationierung das sehen
wir jetzt hier auch es wir stehen in
einzelnen Landkreisen werden ja schon
jetzt wurden im letzten Jahr ohne hin
aber auch jetzt werden ja schon erste
Nutzungsbeschränkungen ausgesprochen
übrigens gerade auch für die
landwirtschaftliche Nutzung das z.B aus
kleineren Oberflächen Gewässern die
jetzt schon keinen Wasser mehr führen
dann auch kein Wasser mehr für
Bewässerung entnommen werden darf und
wir haben erste Landkreise in denen das
jetzt ein geschränkt wird bis hin zum
Verbot
die sind das bekannt ja mit Sicherheit
ne sie kriegen das diese Themen werden
damit Sicherheit im politischen Berlin
diskutiert
wasserrationieren zum Beispiel
wie denken Sie darüber nach ja also das
ist ja etwas was wir spätestens im
letzten Jahr gelernt haben sollten wenn
Politik sich mit Knappheiten schon
existierenden oder potenziellen
Knappheiten zu befassen hat dann muss
Vorsorge getroffen werden da muss man
sich Gedanken machen wie
wie schafft man eigentlich einen Ranking
von Bedürfnisse abgearbeitet wird so wie
wir das letztes Jahr als wenn ich sicher
waren ob das Gas ausgeht haben welche
Unternehmen sind für Liefer und
Wertschöpfungsketten besonders wichtig
so ist es hier auch das macht natürlich
die Situation nicht besser ist eine ganz
schlimme Situation aber man muss ja
erstmal damit umgehen und natürlich
treffen Landesregierung jetzt auch schon
Vorkehrung dafür in Sachsen-Anhalt
passiert gerade eben angesprochen das
was letztes Jahr auch schon passiert ist
also der
Altlandkreis Altkreis Salzwedel hat
diese Woche seit Montag bereits wieder
im privaten Gärten und so ein
bewässerungsverbot ich glaube zwischen
10 und 19 Uhr also keine Wasserentnahme
aus Oberflächen entwässern oder aus
Brunnen weil eben die Forschung auch
ganz klar sagt dass eine Bewässerung zu
diesen Tageszeitung wenn die Sonne
brezelt einfach dafür sorgt dass eine
ganze Menge verdunstet ohne das bei den
Pflanzen was ankommt und das hat dann
auch einfach was mit Klugheit zu tun zu
sagen das muss doch nicht sein wenn wir
diese Knappheit haben übrigens völlig
egal ob wir kurz davor stehen dass das
Feld nicht mehr bewässert werden kann
einfach weil wir dazu lernen sollten
er braucht noch mal
Magdeburg die Börde wie wichtig ist die
für die Landwirtschaft und am Ende für
die Ernährung in Deutschlands
es sind die fruchtbarsten Böden die wir
in Deutschland haben zusammen mit der
Hildesheimer Börde und damit ist es die
Kornkammer Deutschlands wenn man so will
mit entsprechend wichtig ist sie und
insofern ist die Sicherung auch von
landwirtschaftlicher Produktion auf
diesen Böden vor allen Dingen und die
Fruchtbarkeit dieser Böden ist ja ein
Geschenk das uns auch die Natur gibt
genauso wie das Wasser auch die wir eben
entsprechend nutzen können und auch
nutzen sollten also von daher steht das
für mich zunächst mal außer Frage wenn
man über Wasser nachdenkt machen wir das
üblicherweise als als leiden ja sehr
sehr oberflächlich sie als
hydrologischer und anders drauf Boden
ist ja in Deutschland nicht gleich Boden
das heißt wenn es dann endlich mal
regnet ist das in der Börde gut und
dieses woanders möglicherweise fast egal
weil der Boden nichts aufnimmt wie sind
die Böden in Deutschland beschaffen wie
sich das aus ja sie sind höchst
unterschiedlich und hinzu kommt noch das
auch der Niederschlag sehr
unterschiedlich ist wir haben im
Voralpenraum 2000 mm das bedeutet 2000
Liter pro Quadratmeter und ja also das
ist eine zwei Meter Wassersäule die Feld
während es in Berlin nur noch etwas über
500 sind also schon mal ein Faktor 4
oder 5 in der Unterschiedlichkeit des
Niederschlags und in der
Speicherfähigkeit der Böden ist es noch
mal viel unterschiedlicher werden die
Sandböden in der Lüneburger Heide aber
auch in Brandenburg wo das Wasser sehr
sehr schnell versickert gar nicht
gehalten wird auch nicht in den oberen
Bodenschichten werden wir dann solche
Böden wie in der Börde haben die eben
haltig sind das Wasser sehr viel besser
halten und das ist höchst
unterschiedlich beides ist höchst
unterschiedlich verteilt und die
Konsequenz daraus ist dass wir es eben
das ist um regionale Lösungen geht wie
wir mit dem Wasser umgehen wir müssen
uns das für unsere Haustür überlegen und
dort die entsprechenden Umgang finden
das ist die Aufgabe ich ich fand ich
weiß nicht ob sie das mitgekriegt haben
aber ich finde mir gerade ein Elon Musk
was ja die gigafactory in Brandenburg
geöffnet hat da ging es ja glauben die
Frage wie viel Wasser braucht so ein
Batterie Autos und so weiter
herzustellen und er stellte sich hin ich
habe es nicht mehr ganz präzise im Kopf
und sagte was regt ihr euch hier auf
über diese angebliche
Wasserverschwendung ich komme aus
Kalifornien da ist alles braun und ich
gucke mich hier oben und hier ist alles
grün ihr seid bescheuert ihr deutschen
so ungefähr ihr habt doch gar kein
ernsthaftes Problem was haben Sie
gedacht dass sie das gehört haben ich
habe das Interview auch gesehen ich habe
die Bemerkung
glaube ich tatsächlich so ist es so hat
er es gesagt und ähm ich sag das jetzt
ganz drastisch das ist ignorant und ich
meine wir sollten nicht von dem Wasser
Umgang gehen Kalifornien lernen und das
als Vorbild für das wir nehmen wie hier
wie wir mit dem Wasser umgehen denn die
Wasser
Krise in Kalifornien ist ja noch um
einiges schärfer als bei uns das ist der
Punkt gibt es Szenarien die sich die
Bundesregierung auch überlegt für
Deutschland wenn das jetzt so weitergeht
also er Bock hat schildert er gerade
sehr eindrucksvoll es geht um die lange
Linie und wann würden Sie sagen Herr
brauche ich heute noch ganz kurz
dazwischen gefragt wann fing das an der
Punkt
in dem skip da habe ich angefangen mir
langsam Gedanken zu machen es gibt im
Wasserkreislauf unterschiedliche Signale
wir sehen eigentlich z.B Zurückgehen der
Abflüsse in den Flüssen in den größeren
Flüssen diese Tendenz schon länger
ungefähr also zumindest ich würde jetzt
sagen 10 bis 15 Jahre ist es ist das ist
da so ein Eintrittspunkt offensichtlich
gewesen aber wie gesagt jetzt besonders
man die fest und wirklich durch den
gesamten Wasserkreislauf sich ziehen
seit den Jahren 20 17 20 18 und dann
jetzt in der Folge dieser 5 Jahre wo wir
es mit diesem wirklich zusammenhängenden
Ereignis zu tun haben die Frage
Szenarien worüber denken sie danach gibt
es das Szenarien
also ich bin jetzt kein
landwirtschaftsexperte oder so alle
betrifft und wir müssen uns damit
beschäftigen und ich gehe davon aus dass
sie das natürlich tun ich kann das ein
bisschen an meinem Bereich machen an dem
ich im Bundestag arbeite an der
Baupolitik also da sind wir ja nicht nur
Deutschland sondern global auf dem Weg
dahin netto 0 künftig zu versiegeln das
heißt für Fläche die wir neu versiegeln
weil zum Beispiel ein Gebäude entsteht
werden wir in sehr nahe Zukunft uns die
Selbstverpflichtung auferlegt haben dann
auch immer die gleich große Fläche zu
entsiegeln weil wir verstanden haben
dass es nicht nur um die Menge an
Niederschlag geht sondern auch um die
Frage wo dieser Niederschlag dann
eigentlich hingeht und das ist nicht nur
darum geht den irgendwo in möglichst
großen Behältnissen und rückhalte Becken
zu halten sondern so wie Sie es gerade
beschrieben haben das ist da wirklich
auch darum geht wie die Böden
funktionieren wie das dann über Jahre
als Grundwasser sich auch widerspiegelt
und klar das verändert Baupolitik ganz
konkret das lässt uns viel stärker
darüber reden in die Höhe zu bauen
Dachgeschoss Ausbauten zu machen es
führt in Städten die bislang keine
besonders hohe Baukultur haben dazu das
über Hochhäuser stärker nachgedacht wird
weil jeder Politikbereich seinen Beitrag
dazu leisten muss dass eh schon
vorhandene Problem nicht fahrlässig noch
größer zu machen
der vielleicht können wir die Grafik
einmal ganz kurz zeigen die
der Wasserverbrauch im Haushalt was wir
selber brauchen was anteilig für Essen
und Trinken benötigt wird Reinigung
autopflegegarten das ganze Thema
Körperpflege sehr interessant ne Baden
Duschen 36 %. also müssen wir Wasser
sparen wo wo tun wir sinnvollerweise
es fängt damit an dass tatsächlich die
meisten Bundesbürgern unbekannt ist wie
viel Wasser sie eigentlich überhaupt
verbrauchen sind nämlich 100 rund 125
Liter pro Einwohnern Tag die braucht
jeder von uns oder wird von dem
Wasserversorgern bereitgestellt und
diese Zahl wenn sie dann gehört wird
schon erstmal mit Erstaunen zu Kenntnis
genommen zu der Botschaft gehört das war
schon mal viel mehr wir haben vor etwa
30 Jahren knapp 150 Liter pro Einwohner
am Tag verbraucht dann ist also schon
mal einiges passiert das ist
zurückgegangen wassersparende Armaturen
und da sind die gerade in den Haushalten
ist da schon sehr viel passiert zeigt
auch dass Bürger bereit sind dort zu
handeln in den letzten drei trockenen
Jahren ist es aber wieder nach oben
gegangen also wir sind tatsächlich wie
jetzt in der Umkehr dieses tiefen
Punktesystem wir schon mal erreicht okay
wir sind bei 125 l ja ungefähr sagen sie
wo ist weil gerade über Kalifornien
gesprochen haben der durchschnittliche
kalifornia braucht wie viel knapp 300
obwohl er noch weniger Wasser hat
natürlich ja deswegen sagte ich vorhin
das ist kein gutes Beispiel und man muss
noch auch hinzufügen das kommt in
Deutschland zu dieser Zahl auch dazu die
ist nämlich im internationalen Maßstab
sehr gering wir sind eigentlich schon
und haben gerade im häuslichen
verbrauchen hohe wassereffizienz
Bewusstsein offensichtlich ja das zweite
was dazu gehört ist aber dass unsere
Trinkwasserleitung aus denen wir das
Wasser bekommen und die Wasserwerke die
wir haben sehr gut und gebaut sind von
der Infrastruktur sehr gut unterhalten
werden mit unseren Wassergebühren die
wir dafür bezahlen als Verbraucher die
Wasserverluste sind im internationalen
Maßstab extrem gering äh ein großer Teil
der Wasserprobleme die in letztes Jahr
in von denen wir in Spanien gehört haben
aber auch in Frankreich gehört haben
haben auch mit maroden Infrastruktur
wir haben Trinkwasserleitungen gehen
100% des geförderten Wassers verloren es
muss doppelt so viel gefördert werden
also wo wo wo zum Beispiel in Italien
zum Beispiel
dort wird doppelt so viel es gibt dort
trinkversorgungssysteme in denen 100
also die hell also das die doppelte
Wassermenge gefördert werden muss
bezogen auf diejenige Menge die aus dem
außen aus dem aus dem Wasserhahn kommt
und das zeigt wie wichtig
Infrastruktur und die nachhaltige auch
Unterhaltung Erneuerung und so weiter
der Infrastruktur in diesem Zusammenhang
ist auch das ist ein System sozusagen
von der Quelle bis zum Verbrauch dass
man gesamthaft sehen muss das Israel
lässt aber besonders gut sind
unglaublich gut was das Thema das sind
vor allen Dingen besonders gut in der
Landwirtschaft ja und da sind wir mit
der Bewässerung die wir jetzt hier in
einigen Regionen haben also jeder hat
die Kanonen vor Augen die da in großer
Höhe das Wasser im Sommertagen bei
heißem Wind über Maisfelder sprühen
das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem was
man machen sollte und die
wassereffizienz die drückt man dadurch
aus also wie viele sozusagen
Nahrungsmittel wird denn pro Liter
Wasser produziert da ist Israel der
referenzmaßstab heißt ja die sind also
es geht um diese Tröpfchenbewässerung
ist die Technik um die es geht das sind
Technologien die bei uns wenn es in
Zukunft in dieser Entwicklung geht auch
bei uns gebraucht werden und überhaupt
ist da tatsächlich auch noch viel
Innovation gefragt denn diese ganze
Klimaanpassung an der Stelle aber auch
an anderer Stelle ist vor allen Dingen
auch eine
ein
großes Innovationsfeld meine wenn man
sich mal die Mengen so klar macht die
findet immer so diese plastischen Bilder
die die prägen sich dann wirklich ein
gehört Berlin hatte im April glaube ich
die Menge sozusagen alles
mineralwasserkastens die darunter kam
in den letzten vier Wochen war es ein
Wasserglas
also das ist ein krasses Missverhältnis
so plötzlich so schnell trocken wurde
wie war das denn früher wie war das noch
vor 20 Jahren na es war gleichmäßiger
also die Gesamtmenge im Durchschnitt der
Jahresdurchschnitt hat sich gar nicht so
sehr verändert also Berlin ja 550 mm
also 550 Liter pro Quadratmeter die da
pro Jahr im Schnitt fallen aber die
Verteilung hat sich stark verschoben und
zwar gerade wir uns gerade april ist bei
uns in unserem gewohnten Klima der
regenreiche Monat der der die Frühjahr
und plötzlich haben wir jetzt auch
gerade den letzten 5 Jahren plötzlich im
März im April keine Regen mehr und Düren
haben und
dazu zwei bemerken das eine ist es
hätten eigentlich nicht das Wasserglas
sein müssen sondern eben 50 Liter also
fünf Eimer voll das wäre der
Durchschnitt gewesen so groß ist die
Diskrepanz und das eigentlich
gefährliche sozusagen für uns sind die
winterdünnen weil jetzt wieder in den
Wasserkreislauf argumentiert und gedacht
die Wasserspeicher im Boden im
Grundwasser auch in den in den Böden die
fühlen sich bei uns im Winter auf weil
Wasser dann nicht verdunstet es ist kalt
und das Wasser versickert im
Wesentlichen und wird dann im Boden und
im Grundwasser und so weiter
festgehalten
weil von dem Regen der jetzt morgen
vielleicht hier fallen würde in Hamburg
kommt im Grundwasser nicht ein Tropfen
an das ist ein Tropfen nein das wird
entweder sofort verdunstet weil es warm
ist und die Sonne scheint und den Rest
verdunsten die Pflanzen weil die dieses
Wasser sofort aufnehmen in dem Moment wo
es an ihre Wurzel kommt und nach unten
bleibt nichts mehr übrig das heißt mit
anderen Worten wir haben keine
Grundwasser neue Bildung im Sommer
sondern nur im Winter und deswegen sind
die die Winter dürren das ist ich sage
jetzt bei kontra intuitiv das stellt man
sich ja nicht so vor aber das wenn sich
das massiv und dass ich dass
manifestieren sollte dann haben wir ein
richtiges Problem und weil dann auch zum
Beispiel die Talsperren nicht mehr voll
werden zum Beispiel auch im Winter
füllen und im Sommer Lehren und um was
ist die Vermutung also was könnte der
Zusammenhang sein warum sie sagen ja die
Menge bleibt ja absolut betrachtet mehr
oder weniger gleich es kann ja auch kein
Wasser von der Erde verschwinden richtig
ja was ist der Grund für diese
Verschiebung hat das was mit der ich
höre immer wieder Jetstreams mit den
großen Luftströmungen also ein großer
Höhe diese sehr schnellen Winde die
sozusagen das dafür sorgen dass Wolken
um den um den Erdball Rasen wenn man so
will dass die in Schlingern kommen weil
der Temperatur das temperaturfälle
zwischen der Arktis oder den Polen sehr
kalt und dem Rest nicht mehr so besteht
weil sich gerade Arktis und Antarktis
wahnsinnig aufhalten das ist die
plausible Erklärung dafür gibt Leute die
sagen Quatsch
es gibt andere Wissenschaftler die sagen
doch guck doch mal genauer hin also die
mehr als Meinung ist ganz klar die die
in diese Richtung geht dass ich dort
groß gar nicht in diesen Wetter und
Klimasystem tatsächlich diese
Verschiebung ergeben ist das
physikalisch auch plausibel und wir
sehen es jetzt und es ist ja auch so
wenn wir mal schauen auf die gemessene
Veränderung die wir sehen und da ist die
Temperatur der beste Indikator wir haben
ja seit vielen industrielle Zeit in
Deutschland im Mittel gemessen seit etwa
1880 macht man das also seit Ende 19
Jahrhunderts ja schon gute anderthalb
Grad an Erwärmung bis heute und wenn
selbst wenn wir die ehrgeizigsten Ziele
auf der verminderungsseite erreichen
kommen noch mal zwei Grad dazu ähm und
darauf müssen wir uns einstellen also
mit anderen Worten ähm
das wird eintreten und damit werden
Jahre und vielleicht auch solche
Perioden wie jetzt 20 18 bis 20 22 oder
jetzt 23 in vielleicht 40 50 Jahren
unsere normale Jahre sein und das ist
einfach ernst zu nehmen und davon ist
auszugehen und deswegen müssen wir uns
darauf einstellen und entsprechend
anpassen doch eine Frage ich habe mal
direkt am Gazastreifen
am Eingang sozusagen zu Gasa Pflanzen
die Israelis Baumwollfelder die die
wachsen und die brauchen
Wasser aber es muss kein Wasser von
großer oder hoher Qualität sein so also
brackig ist Wasser Baumwolle ist
offensichtlich sehr genügsam das muss
kein perfektes Trinkwasser keine
perfekte Wasserqualität sein und das
heißt die nutzen das Wasser drei vier
fünf Mal
und machen das mit unglaublich Effizienz
bei uns habe ich immer das Gefühl wir
machen es genau umgekehrt wie
verschmutzen auch durch Landwirtschaft
und anderes wir verschmutzen unglaublich
viel gutes Wasser
das stimmt
das heißt auch da müssen wir deutlich
besser werden da müssen wir deutlich
besser werden weil in Deutschland ist es
zumindest so dass man ganz grob sagen
kann aus meiner Sicht dass die die
Einschränkung der Nutzbarkeit von Wasser
auch für die sowohl für die
Trinkwassergewinnung aber auch
vielleicht für bewässerungszwecke und
und für andere Zwecke
stärker limitiert als die Wassermenge
und wir sind immer noch ein
wasserreiches Land wir haben immer noch
800 mm Jahr lassen hier Schlag und der
wird darauf absichtbare Zeit vielleicht
sogar ermitteln ein bisschen steigern
wie gesagt mit diesen sehr sehr viel
größeren Ausschlägen auf der Dürre Seite
und auf der hochwasserseite mit vielen
Verlusten des Wassers für einen
speichern müssten und könnten können
müssten im Winter und es Strecken in dem
in die knappheitszeiten aber das wird
vor allen Dingen auch die Wasserqualität
eingeschränkt und das ist ein genauso
große Herausforderung wie der
der
sensiblere Umgang mit den
ähm vor allen Dingen anders verteilten
Wassermengen